hello and welcome today we are pleased
to kick off the second session of a
community of subjects law environm
and religion my name is Andrew das I'm
an attorney the founding director of a
law and policy initiative called the
global catastrophe Center and first-year
student at Yale Divinity School I'll be
facilitating the session along with my
partner Dina hi I'm Deena Adler I'm a
second year student pursuing a joint
degree at Yale Law School and yale
school of Forestry and environmental
studies and we're absolutely delighted
to have Linda Sheehan with us today
Linda is the executive director of the
earth Law Center where she works to
develop innovative laws and governance
models that help recognize the inherent
rights of nature to thrive exist and
evolve she also has over 20 years of
experience and environmental law and
policy she's developed courses on earth
rights for Vermont Law School the
California Institute for integral
studies and other institutions and has
been recognized as a california coastal
hero for her great work protecting
california's waterways oceans and coasts
so I really grateful to have you here
today thanks for joining us yes thank
you so much for having me it's a real
privilege to be here so to kick us off
the first thing we were hoping you could
talk a little bit more about is defining
rights of nature for those unfamiliar
and why it's such a pivotal model and
perhaps using kind of the framework of
your career and how you're thinking
about how to fix environmental law has
evolved over time and come to a place
where you see rights of nature as an
important tool well that's a great
question and feel free to cut me off if
I if I explain a little too long but my
experiences you mentioned has been more
in the traditional environmental
advocacy field doing work for nonprofits
for a number of years and before that
doing environmental compliance work for
a law firm and so my experience in my
education all led me in a certain path
with regard to how to think about the
environment and how to think about the
natural world and how to regulate it
it's so what we did in you know my
colleagues and I over the years is to
take your traditional environmental laws
ear Clean Water Act your Porter Cologne
Water Quality Control Act your other
magnuson-stevens and try to implement
them as best we can and really try to
you know such smart people you know
working
in California try to push the envelope
try to litigate try to get more
enforcement mechanisms try to get more
funding and really see how much we could
spread this open and really get some
good environmental results and after a
while you do get better at this you tend
to learn more you had to learn how the
system works the regulatory system but
for myself or for me after I did this
for quite a while and God is adapted at
it as you know generally was accepted I
found that we were winning battles but
losing the war we were losing our salmon
runs we were losing our waterways
pollution was still a problem and so I
started to think about well what if it's
not our advocacy it's not the great work
that's being done by advocates what is
it and after some reflection and perhaps
this is another question that we can
talk about more later which I'm happy to
do the the answer started to come that
it's not it's not the advocacy it's not
the work it's how it's structured it's
how we look at the environment it's how
we look at the natural world and we
think of the natural world is something
that's separate from us something that's
distinct that we can buy and sell and
trade and owned and we try to protect it
in part because if we don't we're
hurting ourselves but we're not thinking
about how we are thinking about it in
the wrong way how are thinking about is
separate and we're thinking about is
external and something that could be
manipulated and we're rights of nature
comes in is it allows us to be able to
bring the natural world into our
discourse into how we govern we talk
about managing nature managing the
environment but we really need to manage
ourselves and part of the problem is we
have this very circumscribed way of
looking at our place in the world it's
just us just humans and we need to like
how the Leopold talked about we need to
expand that to include the natural world
and rights of nature as a way to begin
that discussion we talk about human
rights people know what that is but when
we say Nature has fundamental rights as
well that also arise from the fact that
nature is part of the earth then we
start to go well that doesn't make sense
and then you start to think well why
doesn't that make sense then the
question the query the discussion begins
and we can start to think about how to
expand our circle how to expand our
awareness and how to expand our laws to
include the natural world would it be
accurate to describe from what you're
saying that part of where that that new
framework of thinking part of what that
introduces is not only in down nature
with rights but endowments with
corresponding obligations and
responsibilities yes although i would i
would say we're not endow in nature with
rally rights because nature already has
these fundamental rights so not to nip
it but it's important to think you know
the natural world has its own rights
that arise from its existence and yes it
it absolutely encourage obligations on
us and that's part of what we've
forgotten that we try to think about
what we can get from nature and how we
can use nature in a more efficient way
and we forget that we have obligations
that arise from our relationship with
nature and until we start to think about
our relationship with nature with the
natural world with our place and this
larger system in the larger planet then
we forget about our obligations because
we have to have that back and forth just
as in your own family you know your own
living situation you have relationships
with the people that you live with and
you have obligations to behave in a
certain way in your relationship in your
living space this is a larger living
space and we have to recognize our
relationship to all of the residents can
you can you just rub a little bit more
or paint a big picture going through
your advocacy work both in nonprofits
and in law firms could you scribe a
little bit of a landscape in very broad
strokes that helped you see that there
was a gap that needed that this new
framework would would help fill yeah I
mean the part of the problem is when
you're doing the advocacy work you know
your your language is very limited and
so part of its a lot of different little
pieces that started to fit together just
from my own experience and one of them
was looking at just the Clean Water Act
and you hear this refrain from a lot of
folks where you say oh it's just a you
get a permit but it's a license to
pollute it's just a permit to pollute
and you hear that refrain quite a lot
it's frustrating in implementing say the
clean water right because yeah is it is
a licensing to pollute but but what's
really wrong with that and it really
starts once you start to delve into
what's really wrong with that which you
start to do when you're realizing your
advocacies and getting exactly where you
want to go you start to think about the
language of this statute and the
language of the regulations and so where
the Clean Water Act in these other laws
came from in the early 70s was I think a
very different place from where the
implementation ended up so if you think
back to where these laws came from the
late 60s you had the Cuyahoga River
catching fire and showing around the
earth on TV what was going on you had a
Santa Barbara oil spill with oiled birds
you know and then Lake Erie was
contaminated and so it was dead and
Silent Spring had come out a few years
before that was talking about DDT she
had all these very in-your-face type of
insults to the earth and so people i
think came at the the laws in an earth
day in particular with this real sense
of obligation which you talked about
before the sense of moral obligation to
the earth that this isn't this is wrong
what we're doing is really wrong these
insults that we're seeing to the earth
are wrong and we need to fix that and as
somebody who grew up and was a small
child at that time i could tell you that
really resonated with me and that's why
i wanted to do this advocacy was because
of what was going on so when we pass
these laws you know when the Clean Water
Act was passed over Richard Nixon's veto
you know can you imagine doing something
like that nowadays the when that was
passed over his veto you know it said
things like you know we need to stop
pollution you know by a certain date and
you know stop putting pollution in a
paraphrasing loosely for those you know
the details of the Clean Water Act but
it sets a high bar and it came from the
sort of moral connection that we had
because of these water insults but then
when you look at the regulations and
this is my frustration you know to
answer your question is when you look at
the regulations that's when everybody
kind of went home and so they you know
the environmental groups which are
growing up at the time and industry
which was going gosh well I don't know
if I like where this is going got
together and advocated and this
new environmental protection agency came
out with regulations it said for example
you don't have to do all that much
unless there's a reasonable potential to
violate water quality standards so where
you started was this sort of moral
outrage that people had you know and
they cared about the earth they wanted
to do something positive so the earth
day and 20 million people showed up in
the streets and then you ended up with
you don't really have to do too much
unless there's a reasonable potential to
violate standards well that's just
that's just saying okay we're going to
allow pollution to happen until it's
just barely above the point where it's
so polluted we don't want to touch it or
with the Endangered Species Act we're
not going to do anything until there are
so few species we could give them names
you know and and you know just call them
by their individual names so as I
started to think about what's really
wrong with what I'm doing why do I feel
so frustrated it's because you're
butting up against these limitations and
wondering then you start to question why
are these limitations exist when the law
was meant to be something else and that
allows you to be able to go off in a
different direction and capture that if
we had that moral outrage and we wanted
to have a more moral set of laws what
would that look like I can just follow
up real briefly does that does the does
the structure of the rights of nature
framework that introduce the possibility
of a more perspective long-term
accountability mechanism that you see
that would make that more sustainable
whether its regulatory or through civil
liability or anything else well I think
it worth just philosophical it's both
you know it's sort of like whenever you
start to recognize that certain people
who don't have rights do have rights
then things start to change in ways that
perhaps you didn't necessarily expect in
some ways that you do so just women's
right to vote I mean we had you know the
way that I think of rights of nature is
it's correcting an error so women were
given the right to vote to correct the
error that only men had the right to
vote that was a mistake you may have
started out with no right to vote in
just everybody symbol of course
everybody has you know everybody goes
vote okay great we're going to go vote
why would you be say there's a right but
we made a mistake and only giving it to
men so we expanded that to include women
and so now we're doing the same thing
we're using rights of nature not is the
end game
but as a way to start to expand the
circle of democracy to include the
natural world and it allows us to have a
different conversation and yes in the
meantime you're going to be bringing you
know litigation you're going to be
passing laws you're going to be changing
how you do things because this we have
to do and that's going to be hot that's
going to be tough it's gonna be hard
it's going to be a lot of friction but
that's the only way to get through to
the other side and the other side is
where we want to be which is this life
that is in harmony with this idea that
we are actually integrated with part of
the earth so picking up this thread of
rights and responsibilities one area
where the class was really interested in
delving into this was climate change so
in an era of climate change it's very
difficult to say what is natural and
also what obligations humans might have
to maintain what is natural so for
example we talked about pikas and how
these cute little cousin of the rabbit
are literally running out of mountain as
temperatures rise is there a right of
nature for the pika to be relocated due
to man-made climate change or a
corresponding obligation of humans to
relocate well yes and no you're a lawyer
answer yeah so I mean I think you do
need to do what you can to try to
correct the errors that you made I mean
you know how it is when you when you
hurt somebody you know in a legal sense
or in just in everyday sense you not
only have to apologize and you also have
to make amends so you have to feel like
in part of the talking about rights of
nature is allowing ourselves to feel the
enormity of the wrong that we're doing
to the earth and then to try to make
amends and so perhaps for the species
that we're harming we do need to make
some amends we need to try to address
the problems that we have and you know
climate change I guess but I'm sure
we're going to follow up on climate
research on that just yet but but that
particular example puts me in mind of an
example that we have in California where
we have some species of fish that are on
the endangered species list and are
preventing you know sustainable water
management from occurring because we
have to pay attention to these
endangered species which are kind of
getting in
way as people are want to say so what
we're doing is rather than addressing
the core issue that we're taking too
much water out of waterways and we're
violating the fish right to flow swim
and that violating the waterways right
to flow rather than doing that we're
saying well how can we manipulate the
fish could we move in someplace else
could we just let them go extinct which
some people are talking about endangered
species triage is the term that people
are using rather than really addressing
the court issue we address the periphery
and so I think that this example is kind
of the periphery we do need to do some
of that but that's not the core issue
the core issue is fundamentally how do
we reimagine how we live our lives how
we imagine our governance how we
reimagine our economic system so that
that does not become a problem so you
deal with that you know just as we
aren't going to stop you know using the
Clean Water Act because this is larger
construct we need to think about but we
need to do both at the same time you
know we need to use that as an example
of how we need to do things better so
that's why I say yes and no you do need
to keep doing that but you can't get
caught up and just doing that because
you'll miss all of the things that you
need to do it's sort of like when you
have a big deadline and you like say
gosh my desk is messy and if I fix it
then I'll feel much better well there's
always some other thing to do rather
than the work at hand and you have to do
the desk has to be neat but you gotta do
the work at hand so digging into that
reimagining one way our class tried to
start doing that was we created a little
exercise where we pretended that we were
in California we had a river with a
limited amount of water and we tasked
folks with representing the big
agricultural companies with municipal
governments with citizens with
advocating for the rights of the
ecosystem and we realized very quickly
that when there's a you know scarce
resource you come into conflict and it
was very difficult to say how much a
right of nature was how much a rivers
right to flow might be was it how much
it's always flow does a river have a
right to flow in a way that could damage
communities or right to flow when
citizens might need to truck in bottled
water in order to leave the water in the
river and I know when you're writing you
always talk about human rights and
rights of nature as very integrated and
mutually beneficial to one another so I
hoping you could talk a little bit about
how you see human rights and rights of
nature interfacing
and especially how to deal at these
moments of conflict yeah and and that's
a great question and that's definitely
not limited as you know to sort of
nature sorts and human rights there are
you know there's a lot of literature on
the question of potentially conflicting
human rights and so I think that what
you can do is just bring that literature
bring that analysis into the discussion
of how you deal with with nature's
rights and what I found in this question
comes up a lot what I've found in sort
of looking at it is the first thing that
you need to do and this is in you know
so the literature as well is is just
look and see first is is there a problem
you know is there a real conflict and in
many cases there isn't a real conflict
between a fundamental right and a
fundamental right there may be a
conflict between a fundamental right and
a desire but not between a fundamental
right and a fundamental right so if
somebody in California what we've been
having a lot of problems with lately
with water is there been a lot of in the
Farm Bureau has said this that there's
been a lot of outside investment in
almonds in California because they're
high cash crop right now you make a lot
of money almond milk is very popular and
other almond products so a lot of alma
treatment planet and they're very water
intensive so that's been part of the
problem in California is we have this
high cash crop that's very water
intensive and that's certainly not the
only reason that there's a water problem
but you need to start to think about how
you take that which is not really a
fundamental right that's a desire to
make money versus the fundamental right
of the river to flow if they're pulling
water from a river say to feed and
almond orchard then n you're draining
the river so it's not a river anymore
you're taking away its inherent
existence you're taking away its life
force whereas here you're you're
impacting you know what they may view is
a property right but perhaps it's more
of a desire there may be a right to some
lesser extent you know fundamental right
versus called priority rights versus the
secondary rights maybe this is a
secondary rightness as a priority right
there are different gradations of Rights
and different gradations of desires
versus right so it's not necessarily one
fundamental right against another the
question of drinking water is one where
I think it may get into sort of
fundamental right of a community to have
drinking water versus fundamental right
of the river to flow but if they're only
getting their drinking water from the
river then you know you you necessarily
can't fulfill this one right to the
exclusion of this one so what I would
say in a larger sense you know to just
step back with this question of water
which is incredibly important because
water itself is a you know it's
fundamentally necessary to live is the
same answer that I would have in this
the the people who work on human rights
conflicts is you need to look at it it
sounds like a cop-out but it's true you
really need to look at it on a
case-by-case basis and there are certain
strategies that you can do to do that
but you need to consider what is going
on in the particular situation so if
you're looking at it at that level and
you're looking at agriculture you look
at municipal and you're looking at there
like the needs of the rivers in
California if you did it that way and
you looked at it rather than just sort
of say well nature can't have rights
because they all have these water rights
you would see that there's actually
plenty of water it's just how we use it
how we distribute it how we allocate
water rights is antiquated is to put it
politely it needs an overhaul and we're
in the fourth year of a drought and we
may be in the fourth year of a ten-year
drought or the fourth year of a 20 year
drought we don't know but if we don't
start to address how water is allocated
in California we're all going to be the
losers so the conflicts among rights is
a longer conversation which I'm happy to
talk about but I think fundamentally
it's a false question because if we were
draining the river and taking away its
river Ness its essence then we're taking
away its life and I think that that's a
it's a real fundamental violation of ISO
be pretty hard to overcome with a human
desire and I hope maybe you could touch
briefly mentioned earlier your work in
the lead-up to the Paris negotiations on
climate change and I know you're also
doing work at the millennium development
goals in this Cove violations of human
rights and rights of nature if you want
to touch briefly on that work yeah so
what we you know we started working on
nature's rights people would say well
you know what about human rights you
know humans have rights as well and and
how do you measure you know as you say
how do you measure one against the other
and to me you know
working with grassroots advocates around
the world because this is inherently a
global problem I was seeing more and
more that it's where you have
environmental violations rights of
environments being violated you almost
always have human rights being violated
as well so you may have especially in
the case of mining you're seeing more
and more around the world where you know
especially in South America you know
people will come in corporations will
come in and they'll put in a mine and
they'll say you know oh don't worry you
know it's going to have jobs or it's
going to benefit the community and it
almost never does and so you'll see
these just really gross violations of
the environments rights but also at the
same time people who are protesting
getting thrown in jail people getting
very very sick labour you know this is
not properly compensated to the point of
you know essentially slavery you're
seeing this all over the world and so
what I wanted to do is be able to
illustrate that it's not you know humans
versus the environment it's humans in
the environment versus this larger
construct that we've invented for
ourselves again back to the first
question about our place in the earth if
we are thinking of the earth is
something separate from us that's
something that's a natural resource that
we can feed into our economic system
rather than this incredibly wonderful
cherished amazing spiritual entity with
which we've been privileged to co-evolve
then we are going to be on the wrong
path and we're going to see more and
more of these violations happening
because the way that the economic system
is set up it needs to be fed with
resources human resources and natural
resources and it's for that reason that
the UN came out with a report a couple
years ago where they looked at human
rights advocates doing any kind of human
rights work around the world you know
whatever it might be women's rights
children's rights you know whatever it
might be and they found that the number
one the number one problem the number
one threat threatened population of
human rights advocates so most likely to
be killed for their advocacy where human
rights defenders of the environment in
the Americas especially South America so
if you're in the South America doing
human rights advocacy around the
environment a human right to a healthy
environment people trying to prevent a
very destructive mind from coming in
you're the most likely to be killed and
the most recent person in
case was a man who was going to be a
testifying at a rights of nature
tribunal in Lima in December speaking of
the climate change conference and he was
traveling to get there and never made it
and he was found murdered on the way so
it's it's unfortunately on our website
we've got a lot of illustrations of
these and it's unfortunately not limited
you know it's a worldwide problem so
it's just a larger system you know that
it's coming home to roost especially as
we use more and more of the earth
there's going to be more and more
pressure to get more out of it and it's
just more than it can give if I can
follow up on a couple of those things
you mentioned the difficulty with water
allocation you also mentioned the way
that you mentioned endangered species
triage it seems we've talked in in very
broad terms I'm going to push a little
bit on the nitty-gritty because our
class was trying to grapple with what
the what some of the consequences might
be down the road in terms of how have
rights of nature framework would work
how does it does it at this point in its
development have any sense of how to
deal with that allocation question or
let's take it more specifically look at
where rights might conflict between
different species or different parts of
nature mm-hmm perfect okay see worked on
back in 2005 ocean and service see
versus the US EPA you described as a
historic settlement in which they use US
EPA agreed for the first time to
consider invasive species as pollutants
under the Clean Water Act which would
seem to say that invasive species don't
have a right of a natural right in the
same way that maybe a species does who's
originally in that habitat can you
describe how those might play out yeah I
know that's a great question because the
because UC Davis just did or a really
good study about that very question
about how you know you've got different
species fighting for water and habitat
in one particular area and how do you
start to reconcile that and that's you
know in part because of the pressure
invasive species are certainly because
of the pressure that we've put on the
earth and I would say that gosh you know
there's a number of ways
see the u.s. to number of questions I'm
trying to give the way the best way to
answer it in terms of how it plays out
and how the rights of nature plays out
in sort of the water realm yeah i mean
that's definitely something that you
know I've been thinking about and
working with some great work last
semester with some great students here
at Yale and working with some other
great students here at Yale to finish
that particular question is to if you're
going the question being if you're going
to have a campaign in california
specifically around the question of a
waterways right to flow and a fish right
to swim what does that look like what
are the parameters of that how would you
actually accomplish that what is the law
that you would change how would you red
line the water code to make that look
different how would you amend the
california code of regulations to
streamline the permit process so that
you could change over water rights
permits how would you streamline the
waist and unreasonable use process in
the california state constitution to do
that and how would you determine what
the minimum flow is and that's a that's
a science question to it so it's a
science question and it's also a
judgment question because if you say
under rights of nature a river has a
right to flow to be healthy it's a very
different thing from under the water
code where it says a river has a right
to the amount of water that it needs in
order to maintain the beneficial uses
that are than ones that we have named to
wit these are these so it's it's very
different because the river isn't part
of our water right system in California
and I'll get to the second part of your
question don't worry so the way that
water rights are structured in
California you can only get a water
right it for if you divert water out of
a waterway for human use so I could have
a water right if I have a far more I
have a house and I need it to water my
lawn or municipalities have water rights
farmers have water rights but the river
has no water rights so the there is an
argument about water rights in
California then the river doesn't have a
seat at the table it's stuck at the card
table you know a Thanksgiving with the
kids you know and while the grown-ups
decide what's best for it and that's not
the way that it should be i mean the
river is you know the life force it's
what allows us to be able to function
and it needs that respect so what does
that mean is that just sort of like you
know nice talk or does that actually
have hard meaning and you can make it
have hard meaning some places have
started to have in stream water rights
programs like oregon for example
instrum water rights that are water
rights held by the state on behalf of
the river and there are you no
limitations to that which you know we
could talk about more if you like but
there are certain gaps in how you are
implementing it to limit its
effectiveness and partly because it's
coming at it from the perspective of I
care about the river but I still think
of the river is something separate vs I
love and care about the river it's part
of me I'm going to make sure I take care
of the river just as I would take care
of me and it's just as it takes care of
me so you would structure it differently
in a way that we want to structure it in
California that you've been talking
about with the different students it was
quite a bit different and then how you
get at this the second part of your
question with regard to species sort of
fighting over the same bit of water
including invasive species the idea is
you know what Thomas Berry wrote about
and I'm loosely paraphrasing from the
Ecuador Constitution that species have a
right to exist and thrive and evolve and
so yeah you know we play God in the past
you know introducing a base of species
dyking and paving over habitats draining
water and so you know we're paying a
little bit of God trying to figure out
how do we make this better and if we're
saying that a species have a right to
exist and thrive and evolve and invasive
species are destroying native species
then you may need to may need to think
about how you are going to get a natural
system back to the place where it would
be most likely to thrive most likely to
evolve and that's most likely going to
involve native plants rather than
invasive plants which are just going to
choke everything out so if you're
allocating water among National of
species then that's a hard conversation
that you need to sit down and have just
as when you're allocating water between
people or between people in nature or
all of the above you need to sit down
and have a hard conversation and what
that looks like has to be in a public
process very transparent very inclusive
because we need to come to these
decisions together but there are
certainly ways to be able to do that so
it seems some of where the rubber hits
the road here is how we actually get
rights of nature into our policies and
then implement those policies so we have
rights of nature and Ecuador in
Pittsburgh
Santa Monica thanks to the great work
that you've done with earth Law Center
and I wanted to read a quick expert from
the Santa Monica orden it's just good
people a flavor of this language and
talk a little bit about that so whereas
in response to the evils of treating the
natural world as mere property the
worldwide national and local
environmental communities are urging
governments to adopt a new paradigm
based upon recognition that both
individual human beings and natural
communities or ecosystems have
fundamental environmental rights which
should be recognized by the law that the
health of the world's populations and
ecosystems depends on the full
protection of these rights and that
asserted corporate rights can no longer
be allowed to take precedence over these
rights to human and environmental health
and well-being so it's really great
language as other law students and
lawyers in the room it's not what you
normally see in an ordinance and I was
curious with how happy you have been
with the language that you got in there
how well it's been working have you been
able to deliver results or enforce
action based on having this in the
ordinance in Santa Monica yeah I know it
is really great language and the way the
ordinances structure is and this is
again getting to like the the discussion
that you need to have in a community
when you're passing something like this
and thinking about the natural systems
that you're trying to protect the way
that it's structured is it protects
natural systems natural communities and
ecosystems within the city of Santa
Monica and so those naturally because
because it's an actual city those
natural ecosystems and communities right
now include the aquifer that they that
you know they live or on top of and
there are no free flowing waterways in
santa monica it's a dry area so the
aquifer you know the atmosphere is
seeking sort of get a greenhouse gas
emissions of course and then they're on
the coast of course at Santa Monica so
the near shore ecosystem as well and
that's you know because it's
unfortunately paved over that's kind of
it right now in terms of natural systems
but the ordinance is left open of course
to be able to amend it later to include
other systems as we're able to sort of
try to bring those back so the example
of the aquifer is something the let me
back up for a second the the reason that
Santa Monica put this law into place was
because they had a sustainable city plan
that they want
to protect and they were afraid after
citizens united came down that
corporations would come in and tell them
what to do with their sustainable city
plan they'd say oh you have to take
hyper fracked gas or oh you have to take
some sort of a you know one sustainable
source water you know perhaps from a
damn and they wanted to be able to have
more locally sourced water so they
wanted they wanted to protect the
integrity of their sustainable city plan
which is a pretty good plan so they they
contacted us so that we can work with
them to pass this ordinance and that's
partly why that language is so strong
because the people in Santa Monica
really committed and have a lot had a
lot of conversations about what a
sustainable city looks like to them so
part of the success in this ordinance is
they amended their sustainable city plan
after this ordinance came out to reflect
the rights of nature and there's just a
sustainable city plan so and they also
put that as a standing agenda item for
their task force on the environment
which is the one who first introduced
the idea of having a rights of nature
ordinance and so they've been working
since then to try to figure out sort of
how do we how do we move forward to
implement this and so their first
thinking and playing with this idea of
climate change may be having greenhouse
gas emission really intensive greenhouse
gas emission reduction in the city tied
with zoning laws etc that would force a
certain direction and climate change
units to be able to make a statement
about greenhouse gas emissions and
climate change changes and because of
the drought you know that we're having
in calif in california i mean it's been
it's kind of it's very difficult to you
know understate what's going on with the
drought it's very it's very difficult
for city officials to wrap their heads
around it so they've been sort of like
tasked full time on the drought so now
it's kind of shifted to this question of
the aquifer and how do we start to look
at you know the aquifer and whether we
are using it in a way that recognizes
the aquifers right to be healthy because
there is a citizen suit provision in
there you don't want to jump to that
right away so the quest that question
right now is being examined in terms of
how much water is being taken out and
there's not a good lot of good data so
we're trying to figure out how do you
get more data on that how you how you
estimate how much the aquifer how well
it's doing to date it's been doing
really well they've got a good plan to
get them totally self-sufficient on
water by 2020 and they're on track to
meet that but the job is really her
everything but you can't over drain the
aquifer because of that there's still a
lot of conservation that can take place
so that's kind of where we are right now
is that it's really fortunate we have
this provision in the law because it
does protect the aquifer in a way at
California water law absolutely does not
you know groundwater management
California is virtually non-existent and
so having this law in place allows us as
advocates and you know the city cares
law to their pretty good but allows us
advocates to push even harder on some
people in the community that may or may
not you know you know necessarily want
to come around to this idea of the
conservation that's needed so it
provides that tool for people to rally
around and have an enforceable way to be
able to make sure the aquifer is healthy
so in having rights of nature as one
tool how do you see it as fitting into
the wider toolbox that environmental
lawyers and environmental advocates have
do practices like advocating for carbon
taxes or cap and trade support and like
compliment or do they kind of undermine
the goals that you're trying to set out
with changing the paradigm well I think
that the answer that question gets back
to the language that you just read in
the ordinance because it talked about
the rights of nature but it also talked
about corporate rights shouldn't usurp
the rights of people in the community
and the rights of nature in the
community and I think that both of these
pieces are essential to remember when
we're doing our advocacy and as
environmental advocates you know as
someone who's been in the environmental
community for a number of years you know
we don't spend enough time as
environmental advocates talking about
that second piece talking about
corporate personhood corporate rights
and is a larger you know a larger
construct this idea of the economic
system that we're living under that
allows us again to keep nature as
something that's separate that we can
you know reduce into bits and pieces
like widgets and buy and sell and trade
and market and to we as environmental
advocates get both of those pieces as
the ordinance talks about both the
inherent rights of nature and this idea
that corporations should not have the
rights of people let alone you know
nature having no rights at all in the
economic system that we're living within
you know which generating this idea of
corporate personhood I mean that is
something that we need to start to
evolve away from and
I spoke at lunch today and mention that
there was a quote that I can't attribute
I know publicist alone said it but I
know other people have said it as well
that it's really it's really chose kind
of mind-boggling and shocking to think
that we can more readily imagine the end
of a healthy earth than we can imagine
the end of our capitalist system our
current economic system and we say oh
it's terrible with climate change etc
but we don't say oh it's terrible our
economic system is generating this and
it absolutely is so we need to start to
think about what a different economic
system looks like and that that
corporate personhood corporate rights
references a call to do that and I think
we have a responsibility is advocates
not just to talk about rights of nature
and putting that into law because that
by itself isn't enough we also need to
say this is our positive vision we are
going to recognize our relationship with
nature and we're going to incorporate
that into everything we do but we can't
do that without taking away the
inhibitors the blockades the roadblocks
in our way and that's really this
economic system which fortunately
ecologically economists have started to
articulate other models that we can
start to use so if we combine that with
this rights of nature paradigm we can
start to have the beginnings of a new
type of governance system a new way of
self managing to recognize our
relationship with the earth so it's very
exciting to imagine this paradigm and I
think you've beautifully articulated why
it's so necessary to switch the paradigm
but I was wondering if you've also felt
that there are sometimes costs to
advancing an innovative framework
especially in the legal profession which
is based on precedent and tends to be
kind of more backwards-facing have you
found there to be professional or
political costs or push back on you
advancing a rates of nature model yeah
and I'll answer that but I feel bad
because I forgot to answer the last
little bit of your question where you
were talking about carbon taxes and tap
not really sure yeah so I apologize I'll
answer that quickly but to get at this
question of the economic system you know
if we folk what we've tended to do is
try to take the natural world which is
being very you know unruly
you know from an economic perspective
and not really fitting into our economic
models because it doesn't but we try to
monetize it to make it fit better and
that's what I think cap-and-trade is and
I accuse you know fishing quotas these
types of ways to monetize and trade the
environment is our solution to this this
economic system that is harming the
environment so we're creating a solution
out of the problem that you know that is
the genesis of what we're facing so I
think what we need to do and that's one
of the reasons that we especially as
environmental advocates need to address
the economic problem head-on is because
it's very easy to be led down this path
of all we need to do these other types
of activities in order to better
internalize the cost of the economic
system will never be able to do that we
can do that somewhat and we should you
know we should definitely do some of it
but to think that that's the solution is
is is misguided we need to address the
economic system head-on and that's the
real problem that we need to address so
on the political pushback question yeah
i mean a it's you do get people who say
oh well you know that's interesting you
know so or you know what do you think
about this this new water permit you
know and they just sort of flipped back
into the same you know regular
interaction so you know we don't really
have and I'm happy to weigh in and help
and try to push the ball forward in the
ways that I can but I think that you
know I think that people are starting to
listen I mean I do think there's been
pushed back but you don't tend to talk
to people who aren't willing at all to
listen because there's only so much time
in a day and you know you really only
need to talk to people who might be
interested in listening i have a friend
and the legislature who is a staffer who
does water work and a friend of mine
told me he'd said to him you know gosh
you know either I'm going crazy or she's
starting to make some sense you know so
you know it's it's something that's
slowly starting to take hold among
people who are interested in looking for
potential solutions and that's not to
say you know I have the answers the
rights of nature has all the answers
absolutely not you know there's there's
a lot of answers out there but
addressing I think the core issue of
addressing the problem in front of us
everybody agrees
that were not properly addressing the
problem in front of us because if we
were we wouldn't be facing climate
change in species extinctions and drying
waterways and all of the other threats
that we're facing to both in the
environment and to human rights
worldwide that we already know about so
people can agree there's a problem we're
not addressing it properly we're trying
a bunch of different things and at some
point maybe this will work so people are
starting to look for new solutions and
that's the reason that I put them out
there because I know the old ones aren't
going to work by themselves I want to
ask you a little bit about where you
found allies or not found allies in the
religious community as a Christian I was
raised with a deep understanding of
stewardship of nothing in creation
belonging to us but all belonging to god
and I'm very curious to see whether you
found that or whether you found any
pushback or have had no relationship
with the religious communities at all in
terms of the implementation or even just
the theological discussions about this
yeah no I mean I've found a number of
the folks that I work with are very you
know into the religious communities is a
big part of their lives and so a lot of
the people who tend to work on rights of
nature were very heavily influenced by
the writings of thomas berry perto de
seda who were catholic theologians and
gia loggia dei were very influential but
certainly not you know sort of this is
what the rules are and you must follow
me but you know these these principles
came out of there the recognition
especially the Thomas Berry had numb
about the spirituality of the earth
itself and I think that you know for
myself my own religious upbringing was
in the Catholic tradition and so I think
that that allowed me the space to sort
of not necessarily formally as you
articulated have the sense of
stewardship but have this more sense of
belonging you know and care and love and
I mean I think that that expression of
care and love that you get out of a
religious tradition can extend easily
out to and especially as children you
know I mean we could certainly easily
say it's children that you know we loved
a certain tree or we love to forest and
and that was natural and accepted but
can we say that now as adults it's
difficult especially in a work context
and why is that I mean that's important
to examine that question so for myself
the folks in who were working with
Thomas berry tended to be more in the
Catholic tradition there are a number of
Buddhist people that I've worked with
since that also are very heavily
interested in this work from their own
perspective of connection with the
larger universe with a larger your sense
of your larger interconnections we're
all one type of understanding and so I
think that all religious traditions at
their core have that essential
understanding you know I mean that's
where the golden rule is sort of you
know it runs across so many traditions
do onto others as you would have them do
unto you and that I think includes the
earth you know we need to be able to
think back to this question of
obligation you know what are we doing or
not doing you know that we would want
the earth to be doing or not doing to us
I think that question since it runs
across all these religious tradition is
one that we need to keep asking
ourselves every day when we wake up and
have you been able to tactically find
allies for on the ground organizing
through religious communities in the
past in California or any of your policy
work yeah i mean the unitarian
universalist ervice committee has been
very active in lobbying in California
and the in the international level there
have been a number of faith-based groups
that work very heavily at the
International the UN level especially on
mining you know there's a groupon work
on mining at the UN doing advocacy work
that is a high Catholic men and I you
know really just kind of across the
spectrum working together on mining
issues especially where you see
violations of human rights and
environmental rights and we're working
with them specifically on this and you
know as you know throughout American
history in particular you know religious
communities have been at the forefront
of rights based movements so I think
that the religious tradition is a
religious community has been important
in my experience to this particular
right space movement as well I want to
ask you further about the various
international governance bodies that
have been that that have been involved a
lot of legal theorist right now we're
talking about a changing landscape
internationally with governance and
saying that the tasks traditionally
performed by governments are now being
performed
I various bodies such as
intergovernmental organizations like UN
bodies or NGOs or even market agents and
I'm wondering if the rights of nature
framework has any way of dealing with
that another way of looking at it well
let me ask you that first well I'll
answer what I think is the question but
it will be an answer yeah yeah I think
part of the problem and I could speak it
from from 20 years of doing
environmental advocacy in California
part of the problem is that people you
know in state government you know
regular people you know we and myself
included in other areas of my life you
know we've lost sense of our
responsibility for our own government we
need you know we have delegated a lot of
the responsibility and we say oh that
government is not doing such and such
you know but really it's all of our
responsibility every day to be able to
see how not only how our own actions
impact the natural world and each other
but how our government's actions and if
we don't like what they're doing if
we're not educated about that then that
I think that's that that's a real
problem that's a lack of exercise of our
obligation to the planet to be able to
do that so the fact that you know you
could say oh you know the constitution
of Ecuador says you know Nature has
rights but you know unless everybody you
know is is saying the same thing a lot
of people of Ecuador are and
unfortunately the government's not
really listening but unless everybody
sort of saying the same thing and trying
to articulate a new way of living then
we are again just sort of outsourcing
our responsibility to NGOs outsourcing
responsibility to non-existent
government entities that we think are
supposed to do the job but really
ultimately you know it's our job it's
all of our jobs and so we need to be
able to get back that obligation that
sense of responsibility we can we can't
outsource our own obligations for taking
care of the natural world something we
have to do every day so if if human
rights law sets it draws a boundary
between individuals and governments and
says basically we're saying where
government cannot infringe on an
individual's rights that seems like it's
a
it divides an individual from government
in some ways in terms of their freedom
would it be I know that the the full
intent of the rights of nature framework
is to help people understand that they
are totally mutually interdependent with
nature which is the opposite of dividing
humans from nature but wouldn't setting
up a rights of nature framework if it's
parallel to human rights framework
wouldn't that be dividing dividing with
a boundary between humans and nature
well I mean the way I understand your
question I think is Dalia cherelle
answer it anyway is you know this idea
of you know positive rights and negative
rights right so if you have fundamental
human rights and you draw a line between
the humans and the government you say
the government can't violate these
you're basically saying you know the
government can't throw me in jail you
know without you know do cause and you
know you can't like you know kill me you
know unless I have a fair trial or
whatever you know the government can't
affirmative Lee go and do things so you
have a protection from the government
for that whereas you know what some
people think of is nature's rights are
well they say well you know it's more
like the government has to go pay money
to restore ecosystems and species and
you know that maybe both the case so I
don't think it's inconsistent with human
rights or rights of nature to say that
the government can't infringe on your
fundamental rights I mean you are
separating the government but in that
way you're saying like I have a certain
worldview that I am part of the earth
that I have rights the earth has rights
and if you're coming in and infringing
on those rights i'm going to say no
that's my obligation to say no so saying
no is different from creating a
separation it's correcting an error in
terms of how we're supposed to behave
and that's all rights of nature is doing
is trying to allow us to create a
governance system system of law and
economics that shows us how to behave
and at some point we're going to get to
the point where the government needs to
you know because individually it's hard
to you know if we're going to restore
the California Bay Delta estuary we're
not all going to show up with a shovel
and say you know okay let's go you know
you need a plan you need a larger system
and that's where the government is
helpful but you need to build that
individually yourself
and say let's figure out how to do that
but fundamentally you you have to say if
the government you know is trying to
build for example twin tunnels to you
know take water through the Delta in
amounts that is unsustainable in order
to save us from ourselves then I think
that you it's time for you to say no
that that's that's the violation of
waterways right to flow and we need to
say no to that so I mean I think that
you can have a rights of nature
framework and say no at the same time
yeah I think we have time for about one
to two quick questions and one thing
that I think we found really interesting
was how in pursuing the rights of nature
paradigm we're caught you're creating
laws to shape norms and in law school
and other places I suppose we talk a lot
of it should norm shape laws or should
law shaped norms and I was curious how
you see that relationship and the rights
of nature contacts um I think I think
both are absolutely essential and if you
just look it I mean you know what we try
to do and it's it's all very new I'm a
but we try to do is look at other rights
based movements and see how they evolved
and see how they were created in a
vicodin you know throw out one book
reference there's a great book called
bury the chains which is a history of
the abolitionist movement maybe some of
your reddit in England the very first
they would call the very first
grassroots movement and you know the
first one have buttons and artwork and
you know and it was really interesting
because they were trying to change the
law you know to change the norms but
they also had to get a certain amount
and we've seen this with right space
movements in the states you have to get
a certain amount like if people sort of
on your side before you can start to
shift the tide and so they did that
through grassroots movements they did
that through lobbying you know
legislators are powerful people to get
them to say the right things they did
that through artwork they would draw
pictures of slave ships to illustrate to
people gosh look at what this looks like
you have no idea how horrible this is
how immoral this is and they were
successful in changing the law which
then you know people said oh gosh we
can't do that but once the law has
changed it starts to bring around other
people on the same thing with with gay
marriage you know you had to start to do
the
education the awareness even television
helped in that regard to make this the
understanding the norms change so that
you can change the law and I'm very
hopeful the Supreme Court is going to do
the right thing so you start to see that
you really need to be doing both and the
same is true with rights of nature I
mean I come at it from more of a legal
perspective because I'm a lawyer in a
policy perspective because I'm a policy
analyst but there are people that you
know do artwork there are people that
are doing music there are people that
are doing all kinds of other ways to
build awareness and build understanding
people doing you know religious studies
and retreats all of these things are
incredibly important to start to change
how people think and feel and that part
is really important how they feel about
the natural world and how they talk
about it even just linguistics you know
this idea about language is incredibly
important in terms of how we are able to
address these problems I was just
talking earlier about how a friend of
mine Michael McGonagle up at the
University of Victoria coined this term
that I like adjective noun problem and
so when you think about you know the
adjectives and announce that we use
sustainable development green economy
Natural Resources try to write a paper
about the environment without using the
word natural resources all of these
terms natural capital all these terms
the noun is the focus right so capital
development resources that's the
economic system that is controlling how
we think and how we do policy and how we
do law green natural sustainable all
these other terms they're the modifiers
they're the throwaways and and that's
what the natural world is really is a
throwaway in this larger economic
construct so what we need to do is we're
trying to change the norms but we also
have to change how we talk about it to
start with and you know I teach the when
I teach these classes I you know grant
downgrade people if they use the word
natural resources because it because
it's hard it's hard to do and and every
time you do it now I hope you think like
you know how would I think about this
differently how would I say this word
differently and is that changing my
construct of how i can create solutions
and everybody has something to offer to
this everybody yeah
that's great so thinking about these
students and we have a room full of
students here in the Divinity School in
the law school in the forestry school
for folks who might be going into this
field do you have advice for how to
utilize a rights of nature framework or
how to join the battle to shift the
paradigm I think my first advice would
be you from my own just from my own
perspective you know for me you know it
was a california environmental advocate
I you know did pretty well you know I
got some laws passed and and it was
working with really great colleagues on
some really great causes but for me I
could not make that leap to rights of
nature until I started having more of a
spiritual awakening until I started
meditating until I started you know
reading more spiritual literature of the
spirituality of the earth until I
started thinking about it in that way
that is not just the intellectual
rational type of fashion that we do as
lawyers and its policy analysts you know
the something I was used to
uncomfortable with it was not the way
that I was taught as engineering
undergrad until I started thinking about
the earth is something else that
something had its own spirituality that
I was intimately connected with it could
not make that leap and so I I would say
to people you know first you know just
put aside all the intellectual stuff and
just go for a hike you know go go sit in
a tree you know meditate do whatever it
is try to do it outside try to connect
back with the natural world and try to
reconnect with this feeling that I'm
sure we all had you know as children
about your connection with the earth and
I'll just if this is lost questions and
with a quick story I had to do a talk at
the California Environmental Law
associations to the California ABA
environmental groups annual meeting at
Yosemite a few years ago and Richard
love last child in the woods was there
speaking and we all got a copy of his
book and it was that was really nice and
and he said to all the lawyers works
were mostly compliance attorneys in
private practice and in law firms but
you know trying to do the right thing
which is good and enjoying the
conference and he said everybody don't
need to say right now but go talk to
people over the rest of the conference
think about you know when we were when
you were a child what was your
connection with nature what we
special connection with nature and I've
been to a lot of law conferences you
know but never like this where like
seriously for the next two or three days
I would hear strangers coming up over
the coffee pots and saying so you know
who's yours you know because mine was
fishing in this one creek with my dad
and I remember this one fall day and the
leaves were really pretty and and people
felt like they were open enough because
they'd been given that permission to
talk about their relationship with
nature in that way and until you sort of
open yourself up to that possibility
it's going to be really hard to do this
kind of work and I'd say just give
yourself permission to go out love the
earth and then you can bring that back
to your work on behalf of Yale Divinity
School forestry school and and the law
school just want to thank you again for
being with us today and thank all the
viewers for joining us thank you thank
you very much thanks so much